oh
him the other day i got it it took it at
10 45 a.m
i had it on my way home from work at
like 5 45
they had this yeah months yeah yeah it
would actually have been
sort of because i got text from members
after i tweeted it being like where is
this
i mean i'm to go like twice a week
are they limiting the number that you
can do i don't think so because
her rules are that you have to get
tested
right so look if you've been
you've run a member and then that member
that's positive
thank you
there's
there's no excuses
yeah thanks just keep it posted
okay all right
um
so the only thing that bothers me about
it is i hate these tests where you have
to do it yourself you know
yeah this one wasn't so bad it wasn't
bad because she
they tell you what to do right i know i
just always assume that i do something
wrong yeah yeah
and when i was doing it they were like
watching me i'd
much rather
the doctor
and the technicians stood on the other
side yeah
right there let's see photos so you had
to do both you had to
well first you had to do your tonsils
with one put that in a model
then you had to do they made you measure
inch on the stick
ugh
um
uh
at national and nothing but like two
inches of water on even on the fairways
oh yeah we went over to one more and it
was just dry beautiful
nice nice clubhouse dude so we're all
two minutes
wait i didn't mean to redeem the day a
little
yeah i will
it was so nice because we were it was
it was
good morning uh you've heard me talk
quite a bit about this historic
republican freshman
class will have in the next congress but
i want to give you a few facts
half of the freshmen are either women or
minorities
young kim and michelle steele will be
the first korean-american women
to serve in congress nancy mace will be
the first
female graduate of the citadel and now
be the first republican woman from south
carolina to serve in congress yvette
harold is the first republican native
american woman
elected to congress and stephanie bice
is the first iranian-american woman
elected to congress this makes me very
proud as a republican
and as an american it shows that the
party of lincoln
is also continuing the legacy of the
first black american
to serve in congress joseph rainey of
south carolina
rainey was born into slavery and even
after gaining his freedom he received
little education as a child
he was drafted by the confederacy but he
escaped
and went to bermuda and started a
business after the war he moved back to
georgetown south carolina
with his family in 1867
he became the chairman of the county's
republican party
just a few years later he was elected in
1870
and became the first black american in
congress
where he worked tirelessly fought for
civil rights education
and economic opportunity for all now
next month
we are going to celebrate 150 years
for joseph rainey's election i'm going
to have a
party and an anniversary celebration and
i hope you will all attend
the ceremony now back in may
nbc news said that president trump would
need a miracle
to deliver a vaccine by the end of the
year
not only did democrats echo this same
pessimistic view
they even cast doubt on whether the
americans should trust the safe and
effective vaccine
yesterday pfizer announced a 95 percent
effective rate in the late stage trial
and showed it was effective in older
adults as well
earlier this week moderna also announced
their vaccine had a 94.5 percent
effective rate this is the most
important news in probably a generation
and it's because of american innovation
and this administration's plan to
effectively distribute the vaccine to
the american people
dr slawy says 20 million americans could
receive the vaccine
next month we know that a vaccine is how
we ultimately defeat this virus
so we need to help reinforce the work of
operation warp speed
that is why house republicans introduced
are included 47 billion dollars in
hr14 the commitment to defeat the virus
and keep america healthy
which we introduced just last month now
when it comes to small businesses we
promise
vaccines would lift our spirits small
businesses across this country might not
be able to wait that long they have been
asked to do the impossible and now are
facing further lockdowns with no help
from washington
the wall street journal recently
reported that hundreds of companies
that receive ppp loans have filed for
bankruptcy
citing the lack of additional stimulus
payments as the pandemic wears on
but that number of businesses in america
going under is without question much
higher
after you see that the journal only
reviewed
large firms that received loan
forgiveness which amounts to only 13.5
percent of the total participants in the
program
the washington post reported that nearly
100 000
businesses nationwide have already shut
their doors permanently
there's no more time to delay we must
act now we are in session
i call on every member in this chamber
especially the democrat moderates
who complained about nancy pelosi's
failure in delivering a covid deal
to sign jamie herrera butler's paycheck
protection
program discharge petition there's
already 138 billion dollars in relief
just sitting there
it's already appropriated all we have to
do is vote to free it up
now back in september 23 so-called
moderate democrats wrote to their house
leadership
urging for bipartisan negotiations with
republican colleagues
every one of them signed this letter
they admitted that if pelosi failed that
a discharge petition
would be the only resort
well this was back in september these
were 23
democrats i take them at their word and
at their signature
they're in session today they can sign
the discharge petition
and this could be done today help could
be on the way
speaker pelosi's approach that nothing
is better than something
is wrong and everybody knows it and the
american people have paid the price
for it and now democrats are clamoring
to go home for the rest of the year
that's a disgrace you signed a letter
you put your name to it and you stated
that if something did not happen a
discharge petition
you would go to well you know what
nothing happened
your leadership and speaker pelosi said
nothing is better than something
and we watched hundreds of thousands of
businesses shut down
to lose their dream we have 138 billion
dollars
already appropriated already sitting
there
all it takes is your signature and
follow through on what you said you
would do
now is the day now is the time and let's
stop
playing games and let's work for the
american public
with that let's go to questions yes sir
welcome back
thank you appreciate it uh why is it
appropriate for the president as he did
yesterday to call a local election
official who's involved in the
certification of the election
and more generally what is the end game
here for the president when these states
certify
their results do you accept that this
election will be over
um i don't know who the president called
but the president is american says
he could find out any facts that are
going on i know a number of members who
call
their um election officials ask how many
votes are left when's the count going to
take place
are they provisional ballots how many
are within my district we're still
counting a number of
congressional districts they're still
out there that have not been called yet
um yes at the end of the day when every
legal vote is counted
when every recount is finished
and every legal challenge is heard yeah
people will accept
what the results are yes sir would you
support any effort to delay
certification
by the state so that republican
legislatures could name their own
electors to the electoral college
regardless of popular vote
i think i'm clear on all of that i think
every legal vote should be
counted every recount should be finished
and every legal challenge
should be heard and the state should
finish their work
electoral electors
finish their work do you have it have
you had a single conversation about
coveted relief in any substantive manner
in the last couple days
with who with anybody anybody who is
empowered to make a deal
uh well in the house i serve in the
house it'd be the speaker of the house
no
have you talked to mcconnell have you
talked to the wife i've talked to
mcconnell yes and i've talked to the
white house
and could you give us a sense of where
things are going
well the things are still at the same
place there's one roadblock
there's one big wall that has stopped
this the entire time it is speaker
pelosi
um i would think after the politics that
she played in the election being over
that she now put the american public
first she still seems to be in the same
position
but the good news is you have 23
democrats
who put their name to a letter back in
september who said
if you did not do your job speaker
pelosi we would sign the discharge
petition
so now if they keep their word if their
word is true and the letter is right
we can get at least ppp relief going
yes all of this while cases are spiking
across the country
and in congress there's still a number
of your conference members that are not
wearing masks around the capital
are you concerned about that and are you
concerned that this virus might spread
to your colleagues keeping you all from
getting things like
the ndaa government funding and a
covered relief bill done
before the end of the year well i can
continue to get concerned about the rise
in the spike i will tell you i just went
through two days of a conference where
every single person wore
wore their mask except for when they
were speaking um
i think people have been very clear and
understand the seriousness to this
um i think that is why when we
introduced our bill hr 14 we added 47
billion dollars more
to help in any need that we can to make
sure the vaccine moves for
further it is a miracle that we would
have a vaccine this year just as
everybody said it would be impossible
but operation warp speed worked not just
one vaccine but now we're on the
cusp of maybe having three vaccines with
a 95
effective no one dreamed or thought that
that would be possible
now how do we get this safe and secure
vaccine out
to the country the president has done a
lot of work ahead of time especially
with that and that's why we provided
more money
you're utilizing the mater the military
that does this so well
um and dr slawy says that there could be
20 million americans that could have the
vaccine
next month i think that is really the
future of how we turn the corner on all
of this we need to continue to work
towards that
it would be very helpful though if we
could have speaker pelosi to stop the
political gains i mean
how could she send people home i mean i
don't know what to trust on her
because she said back before summer we
would not leave unless we had a coveted
relief bill
but she sent us home then when we came
back she said we would not leave again
but then she sent us home
you now have 23 democrats either they'll
be like the speaker give a word and not
keep it or they'll keep the word of what
they signed their name to a letter
you're advising your conference members
to all learn yes yes
peter you talked about uh in the
beginning of the press conference about
the record number of gop women who have
been at it
uh of course democrats still have the
majority and they say that they want to
overturn the heidemann
as our catholic viewers want to know
what can your party do to prevent this
from happening
well i think that's the law of the land
i mean
despite where you stand on the issue
should you spend taxpayer money for this
i mean that's been clear for a number of
years that's something that even
joe biden had voted for in the past but
now wants to change his mind to appease
a different wing
within his own party i think
now that we have a stronger number
inside the house it would be hard to
shift but i know what the democrats have
done
even defeating a democrat in their own
party in a primary based upon this
belief
because they will not tolerate different
views
you know the one thing you look at the
republican party our greatest strength
is our diversity
of how many places we come and that's
that's why we were successful winning
two seats in miami winning in new york
defeating a committee chair in minnesota
think about california
prior to the special election last year
the last time
a republican switched a democrat seat in
california was 22 years
we're on the cusp of doing it four times
in this election
that's the home state of the speaker
it's also my home state too
yes so joe biden and other democrats
have stated that some portion of student
debt should be cancelled
do you think student debt or some
portion thereof should be cancelled
well i think if you watch president
trump he he did do part of that already
um in the process i think what really
needs to happen is people need to get in
a room
and work on a covert relief package i
think getting the economy back working
again is the best way of moving forward
um on how to deal with anyone's debt
yes the ndaa was sent to conference
yesterday
uh when that comes back the president
has threatened a veto
over the confederate provision that's in
there would you support a congressional
override to get that ndaa passed
i'm not quite sure what the president
said there i think when the ndaa comes
out
we'll have it passed and i think the
president will sign it yes sir the
mining team wants to be
because they need to be briefed on the
vaccine distribution
biden himself uh said that if they don't
get
will coordinate with the trump
administration people
when it comes time why would he say that
if he doesn't know about it
your first premise not your question no
my question is today
should there be coordination with the
trump administration
and the black transition team about
distributing distributing the vaccine
well the first thing i think the biden
team should do is
take back the words that they said
earlier especially kamala harris
to scare the american public about a
vaccine that's 95
effective i think governor cuomo should
do the exact same thing
and then when i listen to my own
governor
i think they should allow this
administration that did operation warp
speed and stop playing politics with it
we have a safe and secure
not one vaccine but on the cusp of
having three in this short time period
dr slawy is not playing political games
he's been planning this
and has done 14 vaccines before this
he's put the american public first
president you have one president at a
time we have the military
putting through and planning this ahead
of time so
i want to follow through and if we can
get people the vaccine next month
let's do it that is what's going to save
lives playing politics with this is
wrong
and if joe biden wants to make a claim
first
in your question was he doesn't know
about it but he claims people are going
to die
well how can he make that claim if he
doesn't know anything about it
i think we have our doctors our
scientists our researchers
they are the experts let's let them work
and push this through and let's stop
playing politics with it
that would be the number one thing i
would do
not hurt he could know what's happening
he rightfully so but the one thing he
should do
is stop saying the things that he's
doing for only political reasons
that is what's hurting the american
public that is what's going to have
people to die if they're fearful of
taking a vaccine that's 95
effective and to play political games to
delay it
in a time that it's spiking
i think he knows better than that yes
i have a question what's your reaction
to gavin newsom
to be being at this you know restaurant
without a mask and all this stuff
well i hope the democrats who signed
this letter are not like gavin newsom
say one thing and do another
if the 23 of them signed a letter and
said if action didn't take they'd sign a
discharge petition i wish they would do
it
what's concerning to me is who was
around the table too from the medical
association
and then to say at the very beginning
that they were outside
they weren't even wearing a mask i mean
i know what gavin newsom has said before
he's told us in california even if we're
out to eat
in the last month we'd have to wear a
mask take a bite and put the mask back
on
um i think he lost a lot of credibility
with californians are you having a small
thanksgiving or a large thanksgiving
well it's my wife and daughter i call
that small yeah well i got my dogs too
teddy and cash will be there and they'll
get all the extra food so
i wish you all a very happy thanksgiving
and i hope we do not leave until we get
this discharge petition and get it done
and we could actually get it done today
thank you very much